right so the university teams have been
participating and it's a fourth year
that this um
you know social blood ground challenge
has been going on um
and there are lots of research general
research challenges
and intelligent voice services and i'll
just mention a few and i'm sure
many of you can think of you know many
many others and i'm
happy to discuss and you'll hear from
the other panelists later today
and in particular um i would like to
point out robustness right so the system
should respond to any utterance
including
out of the main ones and especially
difficult uh
to tackle in sort of multi-turn or
longer conversations right as
you know it's unlikely that a person
will strictly stick to you know
uh talking about uh um
you know an airline reservation without
making some sort of side comment
right um and the other interesting
you know challenge and important one is
that
people might be willing to teach voice
assistance to
for example to clarify their
alternatives or to define concepts
the flip side of it is that the system
should be ready to justify or explain
their responses right there's an
expectation of
some additional intelligence um and
um discoverability right so when how do
you know what kinds of utterances or
what kinds of things can
this voice service or voice assistants
like alexa support
and those are in addition to those
general challenges which really apply to
any conversational assistant or voice
assistant
alex surprise had additional challenges
which including
because it is a social chat kind of
challenge
there would be many long utterances so
there'll be information sharing and
seeking
uh there's those are alexa customers
right there
range from children to seniors to you
know
people um fluent in english versus not
uh you know from all over you know
having all kinds of interests
and so so this diversity is really
you know important and interesting to to
support and it's still a very much an
open
question uh how to do this uh the second
one is
uh more specific to the challenge itself
and that uh it was
focused more on subjective sort of user
ratings and
there's been a lot of progress on pre
factors
predicting user satisfaction this
challenge facilitated you know this kind
of research
and again an open and actually quite
important
challenge is that you know people are
not robots right so there is uh there
are emotions and uh
social um expectations involved and so
so both must be aware and you know in
fact
should be able to help people when they
need it or you know
basically satisfaction depends on being
socially or emotionally aware
um of the person so
i'm going to since i'm a little bit over
time so i'm going to just
point out that there is a lot of
questions a team needs to answer
themselves you know when designing such
a bot right so
how narrow versus why this should be
their
coverage how much to trust the
you know topic prediction when the you
know you have a model presumably
because it is a multi-topic system right
so how do you
uh figure out if which topic the person
is talking to or wants to talk about
um and uh um for example and those are
just some examples or
when there's a failure right so how to
handle it what is a graceful exit from
uh an error right to ask you know
and uh so those are all very much open
and again this is just a
visual presentation of the design space
we had to
we decided to uh address
so um this is one specific architecture
which is kind of
component oriented sort of hybrid
architecture where we have uh sort of a
fairly standard pipeline of
nlp processes like natural language
understanding followed by
uh sort of the main specific mini skills
um
and then where the utterance is
broadcast
to um to relevant components
and then there is the dialog manager
which basically selects
most appropriate filters and selects and
ranks
sort of most appropriate responses and
then the google passes through a
generation
uh sort of component to further sort of
improve the presentation and that
returns to the user and as you can
imagine each one of those steps
is again has a lots of interesting
research challenges
and i'm not going to go through them
other than to point out that
in the social social book challenge is
far from being solved
and there's tons of interesting research
to be done here is just the sample of
the recent work we've
published on this topic and there's you
know a lot more work on going so
for example predicting the dialogue act
if the person is sharing information or
asking a question
predicting the dialogue act and the
topic jointly
um as well as the satisfaction of the
user
and being able to recommend what would
be a good topic
uh to talk about next right so
to have allowed the agent to take some
initiative
and uh also some you know analysis work
on factors that predict satisfaction and
for different sub tasks so this is just
a sample there's been tons of really
interesting work published based on the
social bot and the
alex surprise website keeps track of i
forget dozens of papers that have come
out already
all right and i just want to mention you
know give kudos to
last this year last year's uh emory
team that won the first place last year
um you might
and they've done a lot of interesting
they've done it
a lot of interesting decisions but i
just want to call out a few
um and one is instead of having
a hybrid architecture with sort of a
machine learning dialogue
manager they've crafted a very
uh sophisticated state-based uh sort of
dialogue design with
additional awareness of you know current
events and uh
specifically focusing on sort of
personalization right so when they
rearrange the graph
right or or see or select different next
states
for the bot to transition to based
on uh sort of personal information
learned about the user either from
current conversation or from previous
ones and that made a
really significant difference in how
interested people are
and and this building rapport actually
um
was important and that the bot was not
only
trying to share information it was uh
asking and trying to learn more about
the user and showing interest in
people's opinions or interests and then
sharing their own right so they created
a character
that had opinions experiences and
apparently even dreams
which made for a very much more
interesting conversation than
sort of the previous like i know i can
speak about our previous effort which
was more focused on
sort of information oriented kind of
search and recommendation
so very different approach uh using some
of the components from the previous
years but um really
you know did a great job this this year
and i think their sort of
satisfaction ratings were higher than
like ever in history
um and again we'll find out what happens
this year
so so so there were some lessons learned
right over the past few years
so one of them uh is um you know
basically how do you get a decent
experience with a
multi-turn sort of social conversation
um and one of them and uh
the first lesson learned is to have a
robust dialogue act model right to just
being able to understand what the person
is trying to do right um
second uh be super careful about the
data sources that are being ingested
you know not to provide the offensive
information or just
you know unreadable text as response
especially if using
external data sources um
provide some um even even for
the first introduction right not to bore
people with sort of
uh canned uh introduction to the
conversation to sort of provide some
variability and have a decent
baseline response model right to fall
back to um
if you know when in doubt right what's
going on
375 is sort of really high score which
is roughly where the winners have been
in the past
you know a few years um being able to
provide like high coverage of um
information from different sources um
and
take initiative right so know when the
conversation is about to stall
and preempt it these questions and or
know when to let the user take
initiative so this is like an
interesting research challenge in itself
and make it fun right and we did some of
the work as well
and just inviting prosody right to
introduce
interjections make you know introduce
jokes contextual in a contextually
relevant way
provide interesting information not just
relevant one which is again a really uh
fun challenge to research challenges to
work on
and here is the you know for the grand
prize right
which requires basically consistently
having a good engaging conversation
in addition to having a 20 minutes of it
is to
not only have coverage of multiple
topics in breath but also
include depth right i have a personality
just just like
the winning team in the past you know
year
um have a really good transition model
for
meaningful transition from topic to
topic and um there's been some efforts
you know both in our team and others on
sort of coming up with good um
conversational flows and uh
personalized right so making the person
feel special and unique and not just
you know being robotic is really you
know makes a big difference as
is pointed out right and the last thing
is people when they like it they come
back to talk to the bot again and
so you can't just have the same
experience every time you need to sort
of vary
and provide keep it fresh you know even
for the same user
so lots of interesting things to do um
you know this challenge is continuing
this year and we'll see what happens
maybe we'll finally have a grand prize
winner
okay so having built on that i'm excited
to introduce a new challenge right
so which is to extends this effort in
two ways
one is to introduce uh multimodality
sort of visual interaction
uh which is you know increasingly
important for
complex tasks and second is that it's
both informational and task oriented and
that we're trying
to we're asking people to
develop assistance to actually help
users accomplish real tasks right
and so here's an example task the
initial domains for this year
are cooking and home improvement right
for do it yourself is the
abbreviation so here's an example so
a user asks alexa to help her fix
help him fix a scratch on my car right
and alexa might say something like sure
i'm happy to help um you know after some
introductions which are skipped
i learned how to do this on wikihow
scratches are easy to remove
um you know ready right and the
because the user might say sure so the
um and then alexa would say okay well
rinse off the surface with the hose um
the user might have a question or a
concern right like
wouldn't that make the scratches even
worse and
turns out it's a common concern in
wikihow and the bot can
respond with something like don't worry
spring define scratches and make them
worse or damage your pain
and by this is extractive generation and
that this
passage could be almost directly
extracted from
from the page but it's not always the
case of course
so the user might say okay done what
next
then we go on to the next step scrub the
scratch there with soapy water
all right um i did that that was easy
great
now let's choose a rubbing compound and
polish design for cars so i actually
personally had no idea what those things
are
like i know the polishes but i never
really tried to do anything with
you know car paint um and not
surprisingly
most people don't have those things
handy um
and um and the bot and the person might
say that right i
oops you know i actually can't do that i
don't have this right so is there
something else i could use or where can
i get it i mean there's all kinds of
things that
a person might want to do at that point
and here is a
and one version is for example to
propose a solution which is to
substitute rubbing compound with
something that's commonly found
and in this case using web search and
both might find that
shoe polish is a great you know homemade
recipe to fixing scratches again this is
an extractive sort of generation with
some uh you know initiative to to drive
the conversation forward
and then this continues hopefully the
successful completion of the paint being
fixed
okay so so this gives an idea of the
challenges and an example of how this
could
uh a good experience that uh with such a
task about which of course is extremely
challenging
um ai problem right so i mean it come it
requires solving problems and of course
conversational ai natural language
understanding and generation
web search or information retrieval and
of course human computer interaction in
general right because we're now
introducing visual aids right as needed
uh in some limited way so the
some example research challenges include
incorporating domain knowledge
from structured and structured sources
doing causal reasoning right what should
happen right
what would happen if i apply this action
right it will move me forward
towards reaching the the goal right
interactively guide the user through
plans right so there's planning involved
now it's not just
reacting and trying to keep the
conversation fun
but also driving it towards some
hopefully
uh positive goal and revising this plan
right if the problem arises right the
person is missing an ingredient or a
you know required tool or you know
material
right um dialogue has to be multimodal
right there had
you know visual aids should be used when
needed not always right
and the other thing is that tasks might
span over multiple sessions right so you
might need to go into the store and buy
you know i don't know a shovel or
something right so
so then the user should be able to come
back and continue
more or less where they left off right
which is a challenge for the users how
to design this
um sort of task continuation uh
experience
so as real said we're live now there is
a
more information is available at
alexaprice.com um
and you know if you're interested
and i hope you are please apply to
participate
it's open to university students with a
faculty advisor
um and applications are relatively
lightweight
i mean they really focus more on you
know how what would be the scientific
approach how
uh you know requires careful thinking
but it doesn't require like a
20-page uh proposal and you know
50-page budget right it's really
focusing on on the innovation and the
science that the teams want to
do right and the applications are due
april 16. so
again if you're interested i would
highly encourage you to consider this
and ask any questions that alex surprise
support at amazon.com
and of course um reach out if you're
interested in doing cool stuff at amazon
so thank you for your attention and you
know
happy to answer any questions
thank you so much eugene i wish we had
luck in the conference platform the
clapham the virtual clapping girlfriend
which is a
maybe the best feature of the
application um
i'm going to ask everyone if you can you
you have a
uh on the top of your app you have a
bubble like a chat bubble
so if you want to um to ask questions
you could uh
yeah you know just click on the bubble
so that you have an open trail
on the right side opening um
any questions for you jim
you can also you just you know unmute
we're not that many you can absolutely
unmute and then just
ask your questions if you prefer just
typing them that's fine as well
no no do we have any
by chance any uh um previous alex
surprise participants in the
in the audience
that's right eugene that's not so that's
correct
okay so if there are no questions we can
still you know go back later to um
you know you can still contact us and
enjoy the scoop you are the first one to
get
the information and feel free to tweet
it
and tell your friends if you personally
are not interested
um so i told you to click don't forget
to click on the
on the chat bubble so that you can see
the questions being asked
and also to to motivate you a little bit
to be a little bit less shy
let me tell you you know the classic you
know incentive
aspect right now we are actually whoever
is going to ask questions
uh will be the first one will be
eligible for a gift quotation of amazon
so and even stupid questions so go ahead
right you know as soon as we start our
panel next
we are going to um you know we are going
we hope to see more questions of your
one
everyone um okay so without further ado
let me ask actually all my panelists to
come on camera
so we have do we have everyone we have
andrew we have nikita
okay so i'm going to ask each of you and
i'm going actually to call up
your name as i see it from you know my
screen and i'm going to ask all of you
to um
to introduce yourself there's something
super short
and just tell you know who you are
uh your connection with the conference
maybe if you want to
and uh and what you're doing at amazon
today and i will start with uh
liam you're the first one on my screen
yeah go ahead
okay hi everyone joseph yes you can hear
me okay
so i'm leanne um actually i'm uh
working in your steam reporting to her
so that's the first thing maybe
i'm co-chairing wisdom this year
together with david nellad
and i'm part of the alexa shopping
research team as i said
i'm managing an applied science
team of 15 about 15 people we're working
on
advancing search in alexa shopping so
search for products and search for
information following product questions
and our customers
ask alexa so that's it in
really two words
thank you liam and you're almost done
with the conference will you be able you
and david will be able to read that very
soon
next uh nikita i'm going to ask you to
introduce yourself and i hope that
those of you who were in the uh
influence today heard our excellent talk
go ahead nikita thank you so much um so
my name is
nikita vedhura and i'm an applied
scientist at
the alexa shopping team that's headed by
ol at amazon
so i recently joined amazon it's been
only six months
after completing my phd so i'm pretty
new with
not too much of experience i do have a
publication at
uh wisdom uh like you had mentioned and
i've mainly been working on uh problems
in the areas of conversational ai
information retrieval nlp and text
generation
for various shopping applications so
yeah very excited to be here
thank you nikita next uh
hi so i'm hugo i've been at amazon for
about
four years i've changed a few times uh
it's typical at amazon to move from
group to group to the ones that are
that are most needed or more exciting so
i worked at search in barcelona for
quite a while
and now i'm in january i'm working for
books amazon books
and so many people know that amazon
started with books but they don't know
that books actually has a lot of signs
also behind it
the reason of course is that we need to
recommend books we need to understand
books we need to publish books we need
to search for books and so there's a lot
of
nlp and search behind books and i love
the book space
i love books and reading but i also love
technology and so kindle
and tablet based reading i think it's
changing
the media and we will find new ways to
write things and express ideas in the
future so i'm excited to be in this
space
thank you and as you know i'm a huge fan
of my kindle so everything you do for
books is good for
all of us as customers uh next
uh andrew can you please introduce
yourself
yeah i'm andrew borthwick i'm a
principal scientist
i've been at amazon for about six years
now
um i initially was working primarily in
the area of record linkage
in other words finding duplicate items
in atom
in amazon's product catalog let's say or
finding duplicate movies you know is
is the movie star wars the same as star
wars episode four a new hope
let's say right and so the general
problem of matching records and
databases
um right now i am working uh
on uh automl uh over the amazon product
catalog
right and this is really interesting
because we have a vast array of problems
we have to attack
and um we have to do it automatically
and we're doing it over the amazon
product catalog so you have to leverage
uh textual data you have to leverage
image you have to add leverage
categoricals and numerics
all at once
thank you andrew and the last but not
the least karthik who just was
sharing this session just before we
started so thank you for thank you for
both your services to the
conference and also for joining the
panel so kathy go ahead
thank you well um so i'm karthik subian
i'm a principal scientist at amazon
search as uh
as hugo said hugo and i worked on a lot
of problems in search
before we move to books and i manage an
applied science team over 30 people
uh if you find any irrelevant results or
untrustworthy results i'm the person you
should blame for
and uh i have been in the industry for
about 17 plus years and
three and a half years at amazon and i'm
excited to be part of this panel and
looking forward to interesting questions
thank you thanks thanks everyone and so
i'm super happy that people actually got
the uh the message and they're already
starting to um to ask questions on the
right trail
which is good so between every question
will uh actually
you're cheating but i like it because uh
according to the form you asked a
question i don't know if it was
intentional but
you just wrote q if that was just to
meet the qualification to be eligible
for the gift that's super smart
but do you have and i love it if it's
intentional kudos but do you have a
question
a real question by any chance yeah sorry
i was late to
ask a question from eugene but i already
asked him
in private so maybe we can oh yeah
i'm not sure i didn't prepare the final
questions yet
sorry okay no problem
and so now we have a question for aditya
um asking about
uh uh research opportunities so so
basically you know the
alexa price is really for academics our
goal here is really to
to connect with academia and share data
with academy and
help them you know we really think
that's that's such a difficult challenge
that we need to join forces
this being said of course you know if
you want to help the team that is behind
the scene
building all the capabilities to support
uh the academics you you can have so
that we have openings like that but you
would not be uh
able to uh um you know to compete as a
competitor
so i did yeah um
you you know feel free to contact the
team afterwards
you have the email at the top with them
2021 at amazon.com
or eugene directly um we can talk about
that later
uh does it answer your question i'm not
sure
you yes it does i'm not sure if you guys
can hear me perfect
super yeah yeah we can hear you fine and
now we have a question from
priyanka uh so i'm going to disc to
actually direct
the question to eugene
do you see the question eugene it's
whether the test was the data
have personality trailable for the human
participants
i responded privately i apologize so um
yes
so there is as far as i know because no
customer data is available
like customers are anonymous however uh
task bots just like social bots
you know can build their own inferences
about the customer's personality or
interest in fact they have to
read it to a computer to do a good job
so
the short answer is no but you know it
doesn't we don't stop participants from
building their own models internally
oh thank you so now i'm going to
yes sure you're welcome priyanka
um yeah i'm going to turn um so
uh so the alex price i'm sorry
the alexa price uh is basically we would
have to
uh we could collect our own data we
could make our own models and
you will test it on whatever uh systems
you have
correct yeah so there is a very
restricted version of alexa
skill that will be running inside some
pretty broad sandbox where that's right
so the participants built their own
models
and you know for that skill right and
for the back end and
this models interact with customers
through alex surprise
you know framework which again restricts
some you know
information to protect the customers and
do some
additional filtering but yes i mean your
models get to run
and interact with real customers you
know
thousands of them every day which is
pretty cool
yeah sounds really cool thank you thank
you
sure so now let's go back to our
to our panel list and i'm going to ask
you guys you know a few questions
uh so i'm going to start with uh with
nikita again
um so nikita you're super fresh as you
said at amazon and
and again you know kudos on your paper
being selected as a as a finalist
for best paper and it's your phd work
nothing to do with amazon
and actually i'm telling you guys
everyone here don't forget to
join the closing ceremony at the end of
the day actually
at what time it is you remember
yes it's at uh at nine uh
israel time so it's one hour after we we
finish here
um so don't forget to join us
do join everyone um can you tell us
a a little bit nikita you know um
you know what you're doing at amazon and
what did you you know i told you know
why why did you pick you know going to
industrial research because you know
people argue that they always have the
choice between academia and industrial
research so
what attracted you to amazon
uh right yeah uh thank you uh ul first
uh so
like i mentioned earlier i don't have a
lot of
industry experience so this is my first
full-time job after my phd
um so my first introduction to amazon
was
when i had uh previously uh done an
internship over here
also with another team with another team
within alexa not
alexa shopping so that was my
introduction to working as part of
amazon alexa and the main thing
i would say that um attracted me to
amazon and also to industry over
academia as of now so to speak was uh
the
a huge focus on the so-called uh
uh customer obsessed science that uh
alexa and amazon in general they keep
talking about so
um this is because one of my interests
apart from being able to contribute to
the academic research community has
always been on application specific
research so most of my research during
my phd also has
focused on different applications so um
whatever i develop
should be eventually uh useful to an end
user and should not just uh
sit theoretically as some publication
that is something i always uh
that's something i hope for so um
the science teams at amazon including
the current
my current team alex are shopping so all
of these seem to do that really well
um this is what i've seen in the short
time i've been here so
there's this great balance between
choosing to solve
problems that are relevant to diverse
range of customers and at the same time
uh developing uh effective or
novel research techniques to do that uh
to
either be the current state of the art
or to even beat it
so this focus on both sides and end
users
at the same time is something that has
actually attracted me to in
industry and to amazon in particular so
um
right now at alexa shopping at a
high level uh as i mentioned earlier i'm
currently working on
problems covering different aspects of
conversational ai
like question answering language
understanding
analyzing some aspects of customer
behavior for example the way they search
for products or the way they shop and so
on
and also text generation for multi-term
dialogues
information extraction ranking uh
for nlp applications in general uh so
all of this basically to build uh better
virtual assistants for conversation
based or voice based
shopping so some of this is pretty
related to what
eugene mentioned as part of his
presentation earlier so
i would say that there's a very good
fit between my research interests and
the overall goals of
alexa shopping in general and the
problems
that are being solved which was pretty
important to me and it was a reason to
attract me in the first place uh
another uh main reason uh
i would say is because there's a lot of
active collaboration with academia for
example uh with
amazon scholars uh like eugene and many
others
uh and there's also a continued interest
to do so like in the form of talks
there's this great conference presence
of wisdom is a great example of that and
so on so
um this was another thing that i think
appealed to me a lot about uh alexa
shopping uh so yeah i'm having a great
time here
and i hope to make good contributions to
the team thank you
thank you so much nikita and i love you
that you you start using
the this concept of customer obsessed
science something that we call in and
that we really want you know
to play as a role model for the rest of
industrial research
um now let me turn to uh to leanne so
liam um we already said you know kudos
again and i don't know maybe he suffered
a lot being a general chair for that
conference
it's a lot of work and thank you for
taking the time because the conference
is still not over um
what are actually making this transition
with the customer upsell sounds can you
tell us
how you what does customer obsess mean
for you
okay yes so actually at amazon i mean we
were surprised at the beginning
i must say i've been at amazon for over
three years now
and uh when we heard like the lp's and
the customer obsessed
at the first time you know it was it
seems extreme
but with time we really understand it
it's really an obsession about the
customer
it means that everything comes from from
the customer every problem we define we
don't just research you know for the
sake of it
but in order to solve something uh that
would contribute would make the
uh the experience of the customer better
uh the services that you get better etc
etc
so in fact it's really um it's really
well aligned with uh what i call applied
science because it's science
but it's also within a very uh
problem definition and needs of the
society of
all of the customers that's why why also
wisdom is a very
um well suited platform for publishing
our work by the way
because it's not only the research which
should be of course well-rounded and
scalable
uh but it's also the problem definition
and the setting the insights from the
data the insights from the usage of the
customers
et cetera et cetera so it's all these
combinations that makes it uh customer
obsessed
um oh yes thanks a lot liam
um if there are no questions any
question for nikita or liam
at this stage okay but if you have a
question don't you
don't forget you can post the put the
question on the right trail or just
interrupt us
uh now i'm going to turn to oh yes we
have a question
go ahead yeah i got a question uh thanks
for accommodation
uh so i wanted to understand you know
the um how is the life
of an amazon engineer in that light
sciences domain
uh different from uh someone who is
working more on
applied engineering or as to say you
know software engineering
so how what lines uh could you draw
between the lives of these two
you know different engineers in the same
company
okay i'll try to answer with you so
what i'm always saying is that uh what
um what was the science at the added
value of
of science is to uh solve problems that
do not have a textbook solution
so if we have a textbook and we need to
implement it we don't have any added
value over engineering
uh they do it much better than us we
take problems that do not have a
solution
and we do a lot of research uh
and for establishing proof of concepts
and trying to advance the state of the
art in order to come up with better
solutions so better model better
performance
etc etc um so that's that's one thing we
won't take anything that is already
well-rounded and established the second
thing is the
combination of of the applied work and
uh
external contributions the research we
value and are valued also for the
contribution to the
external research community um i think
this is something very
particular to to science and this is
done
by publishing a work by reviewing
works of other and staying tuned at
state of the art
and as you see by also an organizational
role at conferences so everything here
is interleaved
you cannot do one thing without the
other and
doing it advances us further okay the
moment
we advance the state of the art for the
product at amazon
we it's in our direct interest to bring
it further to publication
to abstract it well to present it to
complete the work and make it complete
uh in order to to be a welfare paper
that
uh we can submit this always uh makes us
think further
and according to my experience it always
brings us to the next step
thank you thanks liam um now i'm going
to
to go to uh to kartik uh kartik can you
share a little bit
you know more about what you're doing at
amazon and and
you're mode of working of you know doing
a sense of amazon
absolutely um
so at amazon my team and i you know we
we do a lot of research and we
constantly publish in wisdom i think for
several years we have been doing that
and uh the focus of my team is to
as i said in the introduction our focus
is to improve search quality and make
sure like we feature the most relevant
results to our customers
and uh relevance is not the only factor
right i mean like you want to make sure
like customers buy the trustworthy items
and they don't have to return and
there is no need for cancellations and
so on so we make sure we surface the
most relevant and also the trustworthy
results
so at the surface the problems may seem
like you know hey relevant results
seemed like you know easy question but
it is not
because uh uh we have to work with
multiple scales for instance we have to
understand the customer query
which requires you know attribute
extraction from the queries and also
uh we have to extract those similar
attributes from the items which is some
of the work that andrew is doing
you know do the matching right so we
have to match the queries to the items
and also we need to understand the
semantic intent of the query so
sometimes
the brands become like you know verbs
like google right so and sometimes
people use the product names equal into
brands like i ipod or apple
like iphones right i mean like people
don't say apple so i think we need to
understand these semantic
information which are embedded in the
queries and also the items and
uh to be able to retrieve relevant
results for our customers and um
some of our problems also include um uh
you know identifying fraud and abuse
uh happening on amazon platform and
make sure like you know um we protect
our customers from
these abusive actions so we work on a
different types of models like for
instance we use uh
graph graph neural networks particularly
with heterogeneous graphs and with rich
attributes
we have attributes of like you know the
items and
sellers and so on and we also
use these graphs to identify you know
the characteristics of sellers and
buyers and
make sure like you know they're all uh
uh they're not outliers right in the
graph so
so to say and um the problem we work
with usually
are large scale we are talking about
trillions of edges or billions of edges
to the minimum
and um we have very lit little label
data right i mean at the scale of amazon
we can't label even like you know one
percent of data i mean like and that's
out of question so
we get like very very small fraction
like point zero one percent of label
data and
uh and again it's it's very expensive to
collect even that amount of label data
to say
right so uh so our techniques are mostly
weakly supervised or like
semi-supervised
and and we have to scale very fast
across multiple languages so i think
that's another very big challenge we're
facing like you know how do we
work on language agnostic models and how
do we scale across like multiple
countries and languages very fast
so that's that's about our work and uh
you know if you go to amazon.signs and
uh search for my name you would see like
most of the work that our team has been
publishing and
um i'd be very happy to take any
questions on the papers or like you know
general work that we do
thank you thanks a lot carthage um
we don't have too much time so we you
know we look at a question in parallel
so let's um i know someone has a
question right away
so now so i will go to now to uh to
andrew
so andrew i wanted to to ask you you
know what are the major area uh you know
areas of research in your group
and also something that is also you know
important for all of us
not only probably for your book but hope
you maintain good communication and
excitement within the
in you know the amazon research
community because we don't have one
single
amazon research organization we're all
you know in different teams so how do
you do that
right um so let's see um
let's um let's take the second question
first
um so the second question is basically
how does um
how do you main uh if this blog post
which taylor just
posted is about a uh a grand
challenge in multimodal tabular data
that i co-organized last year and
uh it was it grew out of a
an issue which is sort of both a
strength and a challenge of amazon which
is that we're divided into what we're
called two pizza teams where you've got
like five to eight people on a team
and you're focused on an individual
problem
and so that allows basically as a
scientist
this gives a great deal of flexibility
right you're tasked with a particular
problem and you're attacking it but
there's a problem of how do you
communicate across these different teams
right and so one response has been that
we have an amazon
machine learning conference uh every
year uh where basically you submit
papers to this conference
right and and published and it's got a
pretty high bar of public of
of uh you know acceptance
but um one of the challenges is
everybody can be working on their own
problem and the problem is how do you
compare
results across different groups so what
i did was i
organized i found there was a
commonality
across many different groups in terms of
doing k-way classification problems over
multi-modal tabular data
and in doing matching problems over
multi-modal tabular data so what we did
was we gathered up five different
uh classification tasks which were k-way
classification tasks in other words like
you're trying to categorize items for
tax purposes
is it food is it alcohol is it
medicine right which are all sort of
taxed differently
and then another one where you're
classifying movies uh
you know let's or let's say songs right
is it pop is it jazz is it classical
is it a string quartet right you know
sort of like hundreds of categories
and so we organized the competition
basically we put this data out there in
a common format
and basically it's kind of like what
eugene was doing but internal
right where basically anybody could
participate in this competition
and groups which were working on these
classification problems
across amazon all these different two
pizza teams could compete
on you know classification tasks or like
a kaggle type classification task and
the kaggle type matching task in other
words is item a the same as item b
so that was a really fun project that we
did last year associated with the amazon
machine learning conference and we're
looking at follow-ups this year
um what i'm currently doing right now is
i'm doing auto ml
over uh multi over this amazon catalog
data
right and there's two different things
that are really exciting about this one
it's multimodal
in order to make these kinds of
decisions you have to look at the text
you have to look at the
image you have to look at the
categoricals and the numerics right if
you think about all the information
that's about an amazon product if you're
trying to classify
you got to look at all that the second
really interesting thing is that it's
automl okay
and so this is machine learning for
people who know nothing about machine
learning right
it has to be completely hands off the
wheel an example i like to give
is that we have to classify every item
in the amazon product catalog
as to whether it contains kangaroo meat
okay because it is illegal to sell
kangaroo meat in the state of california
okay so um um basically i i make this
point just to say that these tasks are
completely arbitrary you can be
classifying an item as to whether it's a
kangaroo
kangaroo meat uh is it a helmet
like a bicycle helmet uh is this item
explosive could this item catch on fire
is this item let's say a confederate
flag which we don't want to sell
right and so the problem number of
problems that are attacked are vast and
so you basically have to automatically
be able to you know
do sort of semi-supervised learning over
a body of of labeled
and unlabeled data and then infer
automatically build
a machine learning model so
yeah that's what we did
well done i'm on here thank you so much
andrew and the last but not least we
have just four minutes unless people can
stick around for one or two more minutes
for you know for more questions
and sorry thanks for your patience uh
ugo so i'm turning to you and uh
and basically you you've been uh you
know for a number of years even before
amazon and you've been a researcher and
a one-on-one researcher
you know in a number of fields so you re
recently moved to the book organization
and uh so you're working you know on the
kindle that i love
can you tell us you know more about you
know what got you excited
and the type of research you're doing
these days
sure so it's funny because i've always
been in information retrieval so i kind
of
assumed that i knew how to deal with
books
because one thing's that it's all about
books right but in fact
information retrieval is really about
dealing with
things like abstracts or web pages
articles at the most
nobody indexes a book and if you do that
then all kinds of weird things happen
and so
there are many reasons i moved to books
one of them is that there is a new team
that is starting in madrid
with many engineers so we can get to do
lots of things locally in europe so we
don't have to depend
all the time on people working in
seattle or in india i like to
to move fast so locally makes it easier
for me in the time zone
we're building a new science team in
madrid we're hiring scientists there
so it's an exciting moment to join them
but also from a scientific perfect
perspective
books are extremely hard items to deal
with
one of them is the size a book has so
many pages in it
that imagine if you do a word a bag of
words almost every book looks the same
because all the words are in it right so
it's not very interesting
the other thing is that the really
important things that happen in a book
they only said they're only said once if
you think about the lord of the rings
when gandalf dies
he says you know flee flee and then he
falls down
there's not a single set that says and
then gandalf died
and then he repeats and then gandalf
died and then he says 17 times because
it's very important
that's not how we write books in fact we
try to write books in a way that we
almost conceal the information
to make it interesting and so actually
extracting information out of books is
incredibly hard and even today
book q a has really low performance so
there's a lot to be learned in that
space
and then as they combine it with kindle
and alexa
you know who knows what what it will be
like in the future reading a book like
you can think of yourself reading a book
in the living room and then ask alexa
question about the
author or the writer or have a
conversation with alex about
about books right that that to me it's
super exciting even though it's further
down in the future
it makes it really exciting and it's
actually really really hard to do
because of the difficulty of
understanding books today so that's part
of what got me
excited about books and i want to leave
at least one or two minutes for
questions so i'll stop
so there's a comment from barwa saying
that yeah same for logging documents
so yeah we don't tend to think about it
because it's
most of search was dominated by by web
search for a long time but web
these are basically documents that were
written to be found which is very
different from trying to index a book
and then you have technical books so you
want to be able to let people
study faster understand technical books
and then you have
fictional books so all kinds of books
that are very different
do you wanna join do you wanna go over
the questions and see if we
select one or two
i i don't see you all it seems like her
internet connections
is gone so i can always take a question
and see who it goes
okay so there's a question here do you
intend to use a model to help seller
associate their items
to unload in the browse taxonomy a very
specific question i think this goes to
andrew
probably or
uh what was that question there yeah it
says do you intend to use such
model to help sellers associate their
items to a node in the browse taxonomy
okay okay so that's um
that is more the kind of problem we were
attacking
with the grand challenge uh basically
right that was sort of a
k-way classification uh
where k is pretty large right you know
because the number of browse nodes in in
amazon is quite large
um and that's that's um
so that's sort of the kind of k-way you
know sort of uh
k-way classification where okay sort of
extreme multi-class classification which
is one of the problems that we attack
here at amazon right
um the automl challenges that i'm that
i'm talking about
uh tend to be um binary classification
problems
um uh are is a major focus right now
like it is or is this item or is this
item not kangaroo meat
um or um multi-class
classification problems where it's a
relatively small number of
classes we're classifying into great
thank you andrew i think i think we need
to wrap up because it's already eight
and we have the keynote the last keynote
of wisdom
so uh before thank you thanking everyone
i really encourage you to come and
listen it's uh
from professor rahan segal from
weissmann institute he's talking about
personalized medicine actually i
listened to
tourist talk today uh today morning and
it was really really enlightening and
very interesting
everyone can relate to it so i encourage
you to to come and listen
uh you all is joining uh join us again
so
i let you thank you everyone okay so and
go go go if you have to run of course
you know
more important stuff to do uh so i
apologize of course you know perfect
timing will go
i totally apologize you know my of
course you know the i lost connectivity
at the wrong time
so so again thanks a lot you know for
joining and this is a little bit awkward
to have it in this platform you know i
was the
first victim of that i don't know if we
got the question from svetlana because
she said
that she had a good question so i was
dying to get it um
do we have time for your questions i
mean if someone is staying around
i can ask my question so the question
was actually inspired by
andrews sharing uh this internal
competition so
i did have experience uh doing an
internship in another big company
and i also noticed that communication is
one of the issues
so when the the number of teams grows
it's very difficult to align the work
that everyone is working towards the
same goal
so i was wondering in terms of um maybe
performance metrics is there something
that you monitor not only for individual
sub tasks
but also like because i i had the
conversation with a few teams and i
wanted to work on spoken qa
and i talked to speech team and
they told me that it's not the metric
they optimized for so i should talk to
qa team that was super discouraging i
was wondering if you experienced similar
problems so you found some way to solve
this
well yeah that was one of the ideas of
this competition right was to basically
put all of these data sets out there in
a common format
and measure them according to a common
metric right i mean in this case we were
looking at
uh the classification task i think was
just on accuracy
and um and basically to say
okay look we want to go head to head
we've picked a certain
uh spectrum in a set of data sets and we
have a certain metric
you know everybody should be able to use
their techniques on these data sets and
be able to compare apples to apples
right so we're
not debating you know
about these questions of what what's an
appropriate metric or
you know i understood the idea but this
is more like
regular events you organize for specific
tasks i was wondering about
day-to-day work are you sure you're
aligned that all the teams
you know can can think that you're
contributing like there's some
you know user performance metric right
that you can monitor
each of the components contributes oh
okay um in other words breaking down a
system among the different
yeah uh performance metrics
um yeah i mean
that's just i mean each group needs to
come up with its own
[Music]
metrics i guess but
this was more i
i feel like one of the challenges is
in terms of saying okay let's focus on
yeah it's kind of like what you're
saying can we focus on on making each
prod each system each uh each component
modular
right and and focus on sort of common
metrics right
where we can get these to sort of say if
we pull this one out and plug this one
in can we say
you know how do we compare these items
head to head
right so is a common metric for the
end-to-end test that everyone cares for
right
yeah i mean this was focused on just the
matching
i'm sorry just the matching or just the
classification
uh piece of it i'm going to interrupt
you guys i i really apologize but you
really need to go to the uh
okay to the parking front now uh
andrew i really encourage you i'm super
happy to see that you know you can
started to strike a conversation
you know in real settings you could have
been able to have a drink and start
talking
maybe next year
right yeah yeah so thanks again everyone
and uh apologies for all the hiccups in
the network as usual
and uh hope to see all of you now in the
closing ceremony and
you know the last talk bye everyone stay
safe
bye